clark county school district is making
big changes when it comes to their
transportation system some parents are
being notified their child's bus route
will be canceled and they aren't happy 8
news now reporter victoria saha spoke to
one parent she joins us live in studio
with more tonight victoria hey sasha
ccsd is canceling at least nine routes
it's the newest issue of the many
stories we brought to you about the
problems surrounding ccsd school buses
they have been either late or sometimes
not showing up at all because of their
driver's shortage in an effort to
resolve this some students will now be
using public transportation
average of 15 kids get on just from this
bus stop including verduhi vardanyan's
14 year old son who came home with this
notice showing her son's school bus stop
on hacienda and south conquistador was
one of nine routes that will no longer
be in service by the clark county school
district transportation i don't know
based on what they're canceling just
this route instead the school district
is partnering with the rtc public bus
system to pick up and drop students off
rtc bus only stops down on grand canyon
and hacienda but a little bit that way
so it's like i would say i don't know
it's farther but it's not the distance
of the bus stop that worries the mom in
this case kids going to be on the bus
with totally strangers you don't know
what they can have what they can give to
for the kids to take to school
it's like major safety issues she says
she understands the school district is
having a shortage of drivers but this
should not be the answer currently the
school district is looking to hire
around 240 drivers
this new change will take effect october
11th but verdanian says she will now
have to make changes to her work
schedule to take her son to and from
school there is a virtual meeting next
week for parents to address their
concerns and questions sasha